right here oh just in time just in time
here we go 40 players 1888 is the
average rating time is the handicap
again ending in 30 minutes coming up
coming up coming up coming up another
half-hour tournament game on charm it on
okay starting up here what do we got a
bunch of other players jumping in pots
or fast pot sir and this thing I'm gonna
put over here on my screen so I could
always see how much time is left I want
to be able to see how much time is left
here let's challenge that pun right away
okay and now what okay I could grab that
night grab that night like this all
right it's a pin it's a pin and then oh
I'm out of the I'm out of it
I got a material plus Castle I got me
Castle I of me just come back Knight
here and give a check lethal for coming
up here isn't it isn't this a lethal
fork lethal this is this is a resigned
time isn't it resigned time mates on g7
nerves g6 move the bishop
I got me what do we got what do we got
what do we got here I'm up a bunch of
material a bunch of material here
f7 f7 leading to me something close to
it
just make sure the Queen's are off the
board that's the only thing I have to be
concerned with and then don't let the
clock low that was weird
move Oh King right here make sure
everything is nice and cozy give a check
they should probably just take and then
okay back to tournament tu-tu-tu-tu-tu
okay let's go here double those points
and let's see what we have
could I think there's a okay French
defense I'm getting this pun challenge
this night it's in my territory and hang
on to this pond hang on to it
rook here I'm on the b2 if the pond
pushes I pinned the night I might pin
the night anyhow and get in see how
though I don't even know what that is
doing what does that move even doing
just pond takes I was stupid okay let's
get this in and then there might be some
checks here clean checks or no the
knight is pinned knight is pinned I'm
gonna retreat back to right here is good
right here is good and then defend my
pond and come back here now and the pin
the knight next I have support on e4
okay they draw there's the in-between
move that was nice
there was the in-between move very nice
I should have taken the pond should have
taken that pun they're ready to take on
F I ready to take on F now they're ready
to take on F again let's come here get
my king over quickly I have enough time
okay let's time burner time time burners
looking for the time burners okay I got
this and I want to put pressure on this
pond I don't want to they're just gonna
be okay this this and then takes a one
rook upon endgame no come on go go go I
got this one but I want to get it quick
very very quick cap remove the rest okay
back to tournament six a bunch of sixes
to two sixes and twos windmill windmill
windmill windmill okay I get this in
should have taken that first okay let's
get this night and then get this in
right soon take this night and then play
here get castled and then get on the F
file something on the F file soon I
don't even know I did that okay
queen - f - and then get the Queen to
this square next mates mates on h6 as
well oh oh in between moves um I'm on f
what what am i doing on the night twice
oh this is a killer this is a killer the
knight is pinned the knight is pinned
resignation I'm on the Queen leading to
mate back to tournament 1212 six six
okay here we go here we go here we go a
lot of time left a lot of time here we
go I think this guy's up there okay he
has six points he has six and let's do
this this should look very very familiar
should look very very familiar and okay
let's get this in we're gonna have a
bunch of exchanges on this square what a
bunch of exchanges okay looking for what
next okay this is a bit scary I'm
actually gonna go for this and allow the
okay never mind
I was I think I would have decent
coordination if I went forward with that
and maybe clean here and then go
somewhere else I'm not quite sure where
I can't get the Queen's off and then I
wanna keep my knight around I think
there's an issue with this somehow okay
let's go back let's try this instead
let's go here being sneaky
okay maybe get my Knight to c4 okay
finally came up with something decent
although I'm dropping a bishop dropping
a bishop okay they didn't see it I
didn't see it I was dropping a bishop
right there
let's come back oh I don't want to trade
that I'm gonna get this and then push
push again push push push again get that
night what's this night doing
it's that night doing take oh okay I
just want to keep it complicated a
little bit so I could always uh burn
some time or something okay
how much time check and then give a
check here and then take and then do
what oh gotta play back here where we
got what do we got what do we got what
do we got just gonna give that up
okay go time time back to tournament I
got it
oh-ho-ho twenty twenty nineteen twenty
twenty nineteen twelve John lime that
was really really tight right down to
the wire okay okay um Oh
let's go let's go oh I should just end
up there that would have won material I
would have just won material that's
winning but this is winning material
Knight to c4 is a killer isn't it I
could push this night away
the queen is close to being trapped oh
come on
I have everything going for me here
right everything going at the bishop not
d6 I'm gonna pile up on d6 or more oh
what's going down it's going down and
then let's get this where's that night
gonna go let's get this out of there
maybe I should have just taken right
away okay let's do this and then okay
let's get that in and I really don't
want to play g4 I really don't want to
play g4 and weak in my position like
that okay now no oh I should just take
it on hey let's get that night out of
there let's get that night out of there
and then things become a lot simpler a
lot simpler here f4 f4 and then okay
come on Fi vaz well I have five coming
up here rook up and over
what am i doing what am i doing how to
defend against this go go go go go go
not even sure what this is what's going
on here what's going on here what am i
doing am I missing here I have I've look
here double up rooks just do this just
to get the okay no this is this is all
right it's close to mate very very close
to me Queen check leads to me leading to
mate this is mate next back to
tournament yes thirty thirty six thirty
okay
thirty six thirty nap nap
okay nap is in the lead dirt nap has
thirty that has thirty and then what can
we get here Bishop here maybe they'll
take on c5 okay we're having this
instead so this could turn into a
hedgehog type of formation very easily
very very easily and let's get this in
this is the structure we're gonna be
working with this is the structure we're
going to be working with I want my
knight to go somewhere else let's do
this and then I could push that night
around maybe soon come back and then
play here and then to recapture like
this right now not really get that night
out of there pawn push is threatened
let's do it anyhow and then get my dark
square Bishop out doing something I'm
not sure I'm dropping upon
I'm definitely dropping upon here they
don't have any time though they don't
have any time do they didn't have enough
time to figure this one out get here
very soon very very soon okay and do
what next I should have taken that rook
rook takes okay get my knight to where
okay what are we going to have here
what are we going to have there goes
that H pun there goes that H fun gotta
stop mates okay should be alright with
this I should be should be is the Cape
keyword right there should be is the
keyword and the rook is trapped if it
goes to the right here okay rook
activity
move move move move they only have four
seconds okay focus on this pond rook
activity check time burners avoid the
rook exchange anything just right here
back to tournament they're out of time
forty to fifty forty to forty let's go
this is so tough this is so tough right
here what are we gonna have this time
there's 17 minutes left 17 minutes and
change I have that timer still right
there the Queen is trapped just resign
the Queen is trapped come on resign you
know you won resign don't let the clock
tick don't be a clock ticker no way
pods er oh this isn't the same pods oh
there it is back to Turman 56 54 I shot
up the ranks there seven games this is a
different pot sir pots are five seven
one six don't get the mistaken don't get
a mistaken it's a different pot sir
okay know what dude what does one deal
here we go
and now coming up here get that Bishop
get that Bishop and get on this diagonal
get on that diagonal do I have it if the
bishop backs up there I have this square
I want to get to this square my nights
gonna get pushed away oh boy okay I'm
gonna go here right now although I
probably didn't need to do that okay and
I'm the queen maybe oh nice move nice
move nice move right there and just move
my knight and there's gonna be what okay
now I could actually take here my queen
is defended before that's why I couldn't
take and it's at this night and then do
what get my king okay right here I don't
want a castle do not want to castle
what are they gonna do they down on time
they're way down on time here just right
here and allow that the rook I hear and
then throw a check in and get my knight
to the center I could do this let's give
another check and now I can rely upon
that home for my night before I couldn't
stop the knife from coming there my
Knights gonna be challenged soon okay
they forfeit on time back to tournament
72 70 54 72 70 54 15 minutes and change
kappa rot is there once again once again
he's up there I like having this time
run off to the side somebody suggested
that to me and I had never realized to
actually just do that come on just pair
me up here this is precious time
precious time here let's go let's go
let's go let's go
click resigning is that what we're gonna
see here quick resigner ok launching it
it's being launched right now fishing
poles fishing poles let's go here
oh okay oh man okay there goes the the
number one guy right here my the
fisherman I'm gonna try and hang on to
him I'm gonna play b4 and then get back
there let's go to the queenside castle
actually Castle kingside maybe my
opponent gonna Castle kingside there I'm
on d6 this could be good this is gonna
be very good I'm on the bishop I'm on
the Queen as well I'm on that Queen
let's take should have played here first
that was still e undermined this pond
threatening to take threatening to take
there well let's come back that was bad
Oh was that bad I want to get at that
King want to get at that King this is
covered Queen a g5 Queen to g5 close to
me very very close to me now I'm gonna
come back here now I have this square
Queen takes their training mate one make
it one on this square this has to be
made really really close to me right
look up and over and then get my other
up to H I'm on jeast g7 c7 that's a mate
yes a pretty quick win sort of quick 106
90 oh that guy is 12 games in people
must be resigned to him what just
happened there what just happened there
what's this what do we call this a
Blumenfeld gambit it's the Blumenfeld
gambit right here okay this is a giant
Pond Center but I didn't really mean to
drop that pond but I have these bishops
pointing at my opponent they are
pointing at my opponent and I'm looking
for the F file play actually let's do
this get my other night here and then I
want to hang on to this bishop it's an
important ingredient for an attack I
believe so let's do this and let's try
this I don't know what it's even doing
but when I open up some stuff here
looking to open up some stuff they drop
the night oh oh this is a killer light
squares
light squares let's take this night
there's God where's the main where's the
may here let's just do this get my queen
get my queen to this square soon making
to threat or no that's not it I got to
take the bish if I took here pawn takes
the Queen defends take the rook they're
gonna take the rook I gotta win it this
way now
there was no quick win or maybe there
was I just missed it but this is this is
gonna do it this pawn promotes very very
quick very very quick promoter right
here okay no checks I could've taken the
rook do that next mate next soon let me
get this guy first my play where I'm
gonna play they resigned back to
tournament I have a lead 110 106 that
guy that has 12 bovi okay let's see what
do we got what do we got what do we got
how much time 11 11 minutes 11 minutes
here actually that little timer that I
used to I I would say that I hate I
actually like it now like steen how much
time is left I used to be left in the
dark I used to be left in the dark but
now I'm liking it I should have played
Queen h4 by the way I don't know why I
didn't follow through with that okay
that I should have played let's try this
I'm not sure what it's doing
yes resign come on I got your queen I
have your queen is my queen trapped
close to it it's like it's very very
close to it I get the bishops off get
those bishops off and then have seven
and on the bishop f7 coming up have
seven under fire here we go
I have seven next I have seven next
and let me just make sure that that pond
does not do anything great let's go here
give checks on the diagonal the King is
uh that's me that's me quick or a quick
kill sort of 130 124 101 armchair less
than 10 minutes less than 10 less than
10 minutes left okay
and let's go for this do I have control
over d4 they're gonna play d4 they're
playing D form okay let's get this in
pin that night can I pin that night I
just played this I get that night okay
get that night out of there and then
develop get developed get on these dark
squares and that night is gonna be
chopped or the bishop connected rook on
C ok I'm threatening this pawn now also
night here threatens the pot again he's
6 and b5 would undermine the knight here
we go a 6 B 5 still underlines the night
let me do this first no I should have
taken with the pond maybe should've
taken with the pond my Knights gonna
the Knights gonna play there maybe push
I'm gonna push and then push again let
me do this first bishop to this square
is probably pretty good and get at this
pawn whoa actually the Queen's gonna
come over here I'm gonna have to defend
most likely I know I wouldn't have to
defend that let's do this the Knights
gonna come in though oh if the night
plays there I got a pin over here I
can't let this night get to this square
there's no way absolutely no way I could
allow that
I better get up here before it's too
late my opponents piling up on this and
they're gonna sack in the meantime I
want my rook on sea to be doing
something soon here we go oh there's a
knight check oh that's a good move I
missed it I missed it and there's gonna
be a block there's gonna be something
here
oh okay at least am i I'm not gonna get
mated not gonna get made it here but
that got a little bit scary right there
here we go how much time is left
oh wait I just dropped something my
knight was hit they missed it though
ah they moved there they were hitting my
night now what okay get this pond weird
I'm still have to fight back I still
have to fight back a couple seconds okay
I have to say fur king I could throw in
some time burners time burners time
burners here here take here push up on
time burners where the time burners okay
push this pond push this no that
wouldn't that would be bad that would be
very very bad okay I have a time edge a
time edge take care
check back to tournament where we got
150 for 150 that guy's still in the lead
right there 150 for 150 I see there's
seven minutes and change I didn't mean
to do that let's make this work let's
make this work here okay let's try this
g5 G 4G 5g 4G five and then grab this
pond come back here and then get my
LightSquared Bishop we're right here
opposite their King Queen to e2
queenside castle Knight to e4 okay let's
give this a shot oh it's a little bit
okay that night is a bit scary right
here definitely a bit scary right here
I want a knight on f6 Knight on f6 so
here we go all right and then bishop
here bishop here I'm on the rook take my
knight let's do this I don't know my
LightSquared bishop could do something
more could definitely do something more
here that Knight is very scary right
here do not like the sight of that
Knight okay let's take this and then
take this okay and now I'm on the rook
I want my King right here I have that
covered my rook is around to watch over
it but just in case let's go here and
let's trade Queens
okay so we're even on time now we're not
trading Queens just
I don't know why I did that move I do
not know why I did that move let's get
my majority going that's how I can make
progress oh this is nuts
this is very very nuts right here okay
they drop the rook the rook is dropped
right here let's do this
and then what rook here my queen is
watching this point so the rook is dead
the Queen's have to come off Queens have
to come off here there we go get this
majority going get it going getting
going go go go go go how much time five
minutes and change five minutes and
change no that's me that's me that's me
back to term at 170 174 175 and change
that guy has 17 games in here we go um
Sicilian land more Sicilian
what do we have
Bishop to e7 castle and b5 they're
stopping are they stopping I want to get
in d4 and then get my knight into this
Square even if I drop upon at this point
get my bishop on b7 + f6 I might be
looking for f6 here very very soon f6
let's just open it up hopefully this
works we hit this and we're having a
bunch of exchanges a bunch of exchanges
I'm on this night I'm on the dark square
pawn and was that mist let's see
opposite color bishops time time time
time hmm let's go here first
oh I shouldn't have done that I'm on
this pond though with check what are
they gonna do okay there might be this
coming up soon light squares light
squares light squares light squares my
back rank oh I should have taken that
pawn I mean then got the light square
bishop that's what the check
that's with check what do we have is
this close to me I have to be cautious
about me I could do this I think now
let's come over here and then what
oh is this close to me I gotta get rid
of that gotta get rid of that let's get
rid of this get my king over how much
time okay here I could get this pine I
think they cash in I got a watch out for
a sneaky pawn move watch out for the
sneaky pawn move okay there we go
things are okay now things are back to
okay let's get this up let's get this up
I get premium stuff back determined yes
an important win 194 191 61 I still
gotta catch that guy he's four points I
had two minutes and change am I gonna
get paired up with him Ozzie T again
Ozzie T again here we go let's see if I
could get I should have maybe okay here
we go
Knight f3 Castle pawn push okay Queen
over Queen g3 I want to hang on to that
Bishop Queen g3 f5 let's do it
f7 f7 hit f7 right now right now
Queen to g3 Queen to g3 are they really
gonna take that queen g3 I'm on the rook
uh-oh
I'm on the roof take out the night take
out the night here
resignation uh-oh
I'm on the rook again the rook is dead
the rook is dead and then just push here
let's get out of that push here with
check and then move my knight discovery
checks discovery checks discover checks
again whoa
discover checkmate yes two queens that
got at to 14 to 10 one minute 41 seconds
1 minute 41 139 138 ah man that guy has
19 games in that's crazy
here we go how much a minute 30 I have
this little clock right here I'm loving
the clock
could we get it could we get it I'm
setting it up I'm setting it up I'm
setting it up come on miss it miss it
okay I'm gonna take the night out take
that night out tricky tricky I'm still
on on on the bishop I'm on the bishop I
am on that [ __ ] if I could give a check
if the pond pushes I'm gonna take the
bishop and then get on the h-file get on
the h-file give it check move your king
move the king and it's mate
ah okay
there's there's also Brooke in the
corner I had rook in the corner
available but I want what keep this pin
44 seconds 44 seconds looking for a pin
pins pins pins pins this and then push
okay what do we have if Rick takes rook
okay now we got this pin 26 seconds 26
seconds keep going why'd I do that
there's gonna be night takes why'd I do
that
I just dropped that piece ah am i doing
I'm dropping pieces here 15 move that
pond maybe they moved their pond there's
gonna be a check how much time oh I
didn't get it what we got second there
was no time to even finish oh man
second place confetti is not as good as
first place confetti man let me close
out what is going on that is not the
first time I've seen that 19 games Wow
19 games to 14 to 10 186 181 173
a lot of people are up there in the pack
214 is very high 15 game if 19 15 17
regarding number of games okay